This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健康和建立复原力的标志。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这更重要的黑人年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you've done. need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your
请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人，基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你必须这样做。请在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。
podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins, but the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much. I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控让人生下双胞胎，但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，在某种程度上。我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，莱斯比安。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们采取了行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。请在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe》。
Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. If you could not tell from my little get up today, I have my tiara on. I have my magic sparkling wand. We are talking about the psychology of whimsy and why whimsy is so uniquely powerful. Side note. I'm also recording this. episode on Friday the 13th. And so I feel like I need this kind of glittery, princess energy to like ward off the evil spirits. The reason I really wanted to do this episode, and now I'm debating whether I keep holding my one or whether I throw it away, I'm going to keep it for the intro and then I'm going to toss it aside. But the reason I wanted to do this episode is because people often dismiss the silly little things we do to keep our joy alive in
大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《20多岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论20多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们要剖析20多岁的心理。如果你看不出我今天的装扮，我戴着皇冠。我拿着神奇的闪光棒。我们正在谈论奇思妙想的心理学，以及为什么奇思妙想如此独特而强大。顺便说一句。我录制这一集的时候是13号星期五。所以我感觉我需要这种闪闪发光的公主能量来驱散邪灵。我之所以真的想做这一集，现在我在纠结是继续拿着我的魔杖还是把它扔掉，我打算在介绍时保留它，然后把它扔到一边。但我之所以想做这一集，是因为人们经常把我们为了保持快乐而做的那些傻事视为不成熟。
life as immature. You know, the trinkets that we collect, the games that we play, the silly scenarios or like dress up situations that we encourage and we love to do. People label them as very childlike and unintelligent and yeah, they don't give them the time of day that they deserve. What these people don't know and what you are about to is that having whimsy in your life is likely going to make you smarter, more emotionally intelligent, more mentally adjusted, more mentally flexible, and a whole lot happier. There is so much neuroscience behind the power of play,
生活中的那些小事。你知道，我们收集的小饰品，我们玩的游戏，我们鼓励并喜欢做的愚蠢场景或装扮情况。人们给它们贴上非常幼稚和不聪明的标签，是的，他们没有给予它们应有的关注。这些人不知道的是，你即将知道的是，生活中拥有奇思妙想很可能会让你变得更聪明、情商更高、心理调节能力更强、心理更灵活，而且快乐得多。游戏的力量背后有太多的神经科学，
the power of imagination, the power of creativity and silliness. And today, I'm going to share it with you guys, including everything from major peer-reviewed studies from the likes of Stanford and Harvard on the power of whimsy to listener stories about what we all do, what I do, what you guys do to keep your life light and fluffy in what are very hard times. Side note, thank you to everyone who did send those in. I genuinely got thousands of whimsical activity examples that I had never thought of before. So stick around to the second half of the episode where we talk about those. but I'm so excited to get into this.
想象力的力量，创造力和愚蠢的力量。今天，我将与你们分享，包括来自斯坦福和哈佛等机构的重大同行评审研究，关于奇思妙想的力量，以及听众关于我们所有人所做的事情的故事，我所做的，你们所做的，为了在非常困难的时期保持生活轻松和蓬松。顺便说一句，感谢所有发送这些内容的人。我真的收到了成千上万我以前从未想过的奇思妙想活动的例子。所以请留下来收听这一集的后半部分，我们会讨论这些。但我非常兴奋能进入这个话题。
I'm sure we've all seen whimsy trending online recently and maybe we're quick to dismiss it, but this is the episode where we really get into the scientific evidence for why it is emotionally and psychologically protective. So without further ado, let's get into it. Okay, now that we've done with the intro, I'm going to throw my wand aside, but I'm going to keep my, for those watching on Netflix,
我相信我们最近都看到奇思妙想在网上流行，也许我们很快就否定了它，但这一集我们将真正深入探讨为什么它在情感和心理上具有保护作用的科学证据。所以事不宜迟，让我们开始吧。好了，现在介绍完了，我要把魔杖扔到一边，但我会保留我的，对于那些在Netflix上观看的人，
because I'm going to keep my little tiara on because I feel like it's appropriate. But like I said before, whimsy is one of those things that you know it when you see it, but you especially know it when you feel it because it's just so light and playful. And there is a part of you that really can tap into it and feels differently. The best description of whimsy that I've ever seen came from a therapist in Colorado, whose name I am forgetting in this very moment. But what she basically said was that whimsy is playfulness deliberately woven into the ordinary. And I think that is the best description I could come up with or she could come up with.
因为我会戴着我的小皇冠，因为我觉得这很合适。但就像我之前说的，奇思妙想是那种你看到它就知道的东西，但当你感觉到它时，你尤其知道它，因为它太轻盈和俏皮了。你身体里有一部分真的可以利用它，感觉不同。我见过的关于奇思妙想最好的描述来自科罗拉多州的一位治疗师，我现在忘了她的名字。但她基本上说的是，奇思妙想是故意编织进平凡生活中的俏皮感。我认为这是我能想到的或她能想到的最好的描述。
It is doing things just for the sake of doing them because they are strange, because they are humorous, because they are fun and nostalgic. And a core part of this is that they don't have to serve any other purpose, right? They don't have to be productive. It is why we'd like to blow bubbles as you walk down the street or collect trinkets. It's playing dress-ups. It's dancing in the woods. It's using the good candle that you normally save.
它只是为了做而做，因为它们很奇怪，因为它们幽默，因为它们有趣和怀旧。而这其中的核心部分是它们不需要服务于任何其他目的，对吧？它们不需要有成效。这就是为什么我们喜欢在街上走的时候吹泡泡或收集小饰品。这是玩装扮。这是在树林里跳舞。这是使用你通常舍不得用的好蜡烛。
It's like baking a chocolate cake just because you felt like it. Just because it brings you joy. What's interesting to me, actually, as a little sidebar is how feminized whimsy really is. A lot of what we see is whimsical. started to realize is just domestic tasks or domestic activities like that are solely reserved for women now being reclaimed as fun for women like baking, frolicking, dressing up, collecting. You know, another huge part of whimsy is it's very childlike, right? It's very nostalgic, which we're going to get into a lot more later on. But whimsy and the way that it's now nowadays
就像烤一个巧克力蛋糕，只是因为你想吃。只是因为它给你带来快乐。对我来说有趣的是，作为一个小侧边栏，奇思妙想是多么女性化。我们看到的很多奇思妙想。开始意识到这只是家务活或家务活动，比如那些专门留给女性的，现在被重新定义为女性的乐趣，比如烘焙、嬉戏、装扮、收集。你知道，奇思妙想的另一个巨大组成部分是它非常幼稚，对吧？它非常怀旧，我们稍后会深入探讨。但奇思妙想以及它在当今的呈现方式，
portrayed, it's not just reserved for one gender or, indeed just for children. And I fear that some of the framing that's taking place, especially online, might exclude a lot of people who could genuinely use its psychological benefits. Whimsie can also be more traditionally masculine as well. Adventure, building something by hand that you could probably go out and buy. That would be better. And indeed, also frolicing, also cooking, also dancing, and being present. Whimsy is for everyone, because it's truly about return. to this very core, ghouy, gentler part of yourself that has been, not to sound severe,
它不仅仅是留给一种性别，或者确实不仅仅是留给儿童。我担心现在正在发生的一些框架，特别是在网上，可能会排除许多真正可以利用其心理益处的人。奇思妙想也可以更传统地男性化。冒险，亲手建造一些你可能可以直接买到的东西。那会更好。当然，还有嬉戏、烹饪、跳舞和活在当下。奇思妙想适合每个人，因为它真正关于回归。回到你内心深处那个粘糊糊、更温柔的部分，那个部分一直以来，不是为了听起来很严重，
but like, kind of lost to the grief of growing up and seeing how harsh the world can really be. I think this is why we are seeing such like a reclamation or a resurgence of whimsy, especially in recent years, almost as like a psychological and mental protest of the equally pressing trends of like the 5 a.m. morning routines and productivity planners and hustling and ambition blocked days and 10 liters of water 10,000 steps, 10 squeezes of a lemon at 10 a.m. 10,000 of hours of habits and discipline. Like, whimsy is the antithesis of all this and people are getting sick of feeling like their lives need to be so structured and organized and perfect. and it's kind of this completely contradictory attitude that says,
而是像，有点迷失在成长的悲伤中，看到世界真的可以有多么严酷。我认为这就是为什么我们看到奇思妙想的这种回收或复兴，特别是在近年来，几乎就像是对同样紧迫的趋势的一种心理和精神抗议，比如早上5点的例行公事、生产力规划师、忙碌和雄心勃勃的封锁日、10升水、10000步、上午10点挤10次柠檬、10000小时的习惯和纪律。就像，奇思妙想是所有这一切的对立面，人们厌倦了感觉他们的生活需要如此结构化、有组织和完美。这是一种完全矛盾的态度，它说，
let's not look for ways to be more productive. Let's actually not look for purpose and everything we do. Let's just exist and appreciate how special and silly life really is for no other reason other than that we can. Obviously, people have then realized they can make a lot of money off that feeling as they can make money off of any human feeling these days. And that has definitely branched off into a few big trends that we've seen come and go in the past few years that are a direct response to, you know, our need for more whimsy. But it's just been packaged by people who can make money off of it.
让我们不要寻找提高生产力的方法。让我们实际上不要在所做的每一件事中寻找目的。让我们只是存在并欣赏生活是多么特别和愚蠢，除了我们可以这样做之外，没有其他原因。显然，人们随后意识到他们可以从这种感觉中赚很多钱，就像他们这些天可以从任何人类感觉中赚钱一样。这绝对分支成了过去几年我们看到来来去去的几个大趋势，这是对我们对更多奇思妙想的需求的直接回应。但它只是被那些能从中赚钱的人包装起来了。
So like the biggest and most obvious one was cottage court, right? The idea of slow living and collecting produce and dressing cute and in flowy skirts and floral patterns and having the gig and bed sheets. then brands like Sheen and Amazon marketed that for us and made the cute strawberry dresses and made like the sticker books and made like all that stuff. Another one was Fairy Corps. There was definitely this whole, I think it's kind of still ongoing of people like playing dress-ups and I guess I'm wearing the little crown right now, people wearing crowns. And now I think the next like iteration of that and don't hate me for saying this,
所以最大的、最明显的一个是Cottage Core，对吧？慢生活的理念，收集农产品，穿得可爱，穿飘逸的裙子和花卉图案，还有床单。然后Sheen和Amazon等品牌为我们推销了这一点，制作了可爱的草莓裙，制作了贴纸书，制作了所有这些东西。另一个是Fairy Core。绝对有整个，我认为它还在进行中，人们玩装扮，我想我现在戴着小皇冠，人们戴着皇冠。现在我认为下一个迭代，别因为我说这个而恨我，
But I think the resurgence of analog activities and arts and crafts and snail mail and junk journaling, that is the next whimsy trend. That is the next way that we are trying to adopt more whimsy into our lives. And I really hope at last. Like I so hope that this is the trend, the whimsy trend that sticks and won't just produce more landfill. Because like I said, whimsy in activities like this, ones that serve no purpose other than joy, are really important, especially in this day and age, hence why they're trending. You know, a core part of why whimsy is so great is that it's choosing to focus on the good, right?
但我认为模拟活动、艺术和手工艺、蜗牛邮件和垃圾日记的复兴，那是下一个奇思妙想趋势。这是我们试图在生活中采用更多奇思妙想的下一种方式。我真的希望它能持续下去。我非常希望这是趋势，那个会坚持下去的奇思妙想趋势，不会只是产生更多的垃圾填埋场。因为就像我说的，像这样的活动中的奇思妙想，那些除了快乐之外没有任何目的的活动，真的很重要，特别是在这个时代，这就是为什么它们在流行。你知道，奇思妙想之所以如此伟大的核心部分是它选择关注美好，对吧？
Particularly what feels nice and light and enjoyable for the mind and for the soul. There's this core cognitive psychology principle that what you choose to focus on expands and dominates your mindset. and what you don't focus on, you know, hopefully doesn't have as much of a say on your mindset and doesn't hurt you as much. Right now, the world is a pretty despicable place. And sometimes that's all we can focus on. And that's the only thing we can pay attention to. And if that is the only thing you can pay attention to,
特别是那些对思想和灵魂感觉良好、轻松和愉快的东西。有一个核心认知心理学原则，即你选择关注什么，它就会扩展并主导你的心态。而你不关注的东西，你知道，希望它不会对你的心态有太大的发言权，也不会伤害你那么多。现在，世界是一个相当卑鄙的地方。有时这就是我们能关注的一切。这就是我们唯一能注意到的事情。如果这是你唯一能注意到的事情，
you could very easily become convinced that this is the one thing that the world is. The world is just terrible. Like in its singularity, the world is just cruel, the world is just evil, life is only about struggle and life is only hard, because that's what's really being pushed into our face. And also, not push, like just looking around anywhere, it's, you don't have to search for how terrible things are. And that, like, the deep psychological pessimism that this creates can actually increase our sense of powerlessness, because everything we're facing feels totally immovable. No human mind, no human soul can survive in a mental environment where they truly believe that the world is just truly evil and incapable of change. So making whimsy a spiritual and psychological practice for ourselves, that breaks that pessimism loop. Even just occasionally, it diverts your attention to all the good that still exists. And we really need that more than ever. when we hear people say joy is resistance, right?
你很容易就会确信这就是世界的一切。世界只是可怕的。就像在它的单一性中，世界只是残酷的，世界只是邪恶的，生活只是关于挣扎，生活只是艰难的，因为这就是真正被推到我们面前的东西。而且，不是推，就像环顾四周，你不需要寻找事情有多糟糕。而且，这所创造的深刻心理悲观主义实际上可以增加我们的无力感，因为我们面临的一切都感觉完全不可动摇。没有人类的思想，没有人类的灵魂可以在一个他们真正相信世界只是真正邪恶且无法改变的心理环境中生存。所以把奇思妙想作为我们自己的精神和心理实践，这打破了那种悲观循环。即使只是偶尔，它也会把你的注意力转移到仍然存在的所有美好事物上。我们比以往任何时候都更需要这一点。当我们听到人们说快乐就是抵抗时，对吧？
This is what I always think of. Whimsy, joy, those practices restock. They restock like your mental and emotional reserves so that you can go on. Especially, separately, if you're in your 20s, it can quickly feel like during this decade that life is just an endless to-do list and you're really finally being exposed to what true adulthood is like and more and more people expect things from you, more and more tasks are required from you,
这就是我总是想到的。奇思妙想，快乐，那些练习补充。它们补充你的心理和情感储备，以便你可以继续前进。特别是，另外，如果你在20多岁，在这个十年里，生活很快就会感觉就像一个无尽的待办事项清单，你终于真正接触到了真正的成年生活是什么样的，越来越多的人对你有期望，需要你完成越来越多的任务，
there is no answer for anything, everything is confusing, you have no idea what the next five years is going to be, like there's this real whiplash into adulthood that can be really hard. And having whimsy in those moments, as a lot of us are choosing to do and choosing to pursue, you know, something as simple as putting a ribbon on your back
没有任何事情有答案，一切都很混乱，你根本不知道未来五年会怎样，就像有一种进入成年期的真正鞭打，这可能真的很艰难。在那些时刻拥有奇思妙想，正如我们许多人选择做的那样，选择追求，你知道，像在你的背上系一条丝带这样简单的事情
or putting a cute figurine on your windowsill for people to enjoy, or like having a cupcake with lunch, that's not silly. That's really helpful in times when the world just constantly feels like it needs something from us. Part of this is also because whimsy allows you to stop taking certain things too seriously. And know that now I'm not referring to global and political things. I'm talking about personal things, but when you have whimsy in your life, the mistrain, the slow walker, like the rejection email from that job you applied for,
或者在窗台上放一个可爱的小雕像供人们欣赏，或者像午餐时吃个纸杯蛋糕，那并不愚蠢。在世界总是感觉需要我们做点什么的时候，这真的很有帮助。这部分也是因为奇思妙想让你停止对某些事情过于认真。我知道我现在不是指全球和政治事务。我说的是个人事务，但当你生活中拥有奇思妙想时，比如火车晚点、走路慢的人、你申请的那份工作的拒绝信，
we don't overinvest in it as much. And when our mind does over invest in that stuff, because there's nothing else to break up just our sense of failure or frustration, we actually hinder our brain's ability to rewire itself. When we only focus on the negative and the bad, that stunts our cognitive ability for transformation. Let's break into some neuroscience. for a second to explain why this is.
我们不会在上面投入太多。当我们的思想确实在那些事情上投入过多时，因为没有其他东西可以打破我们对失败或挫折的感觉，我们实际上阻碍了大脑重塑自身的能力。当我们只关注消极和糟糕的事情时，这会阻碍我们转化的认知能力。让我们进入一些神经科学。一秒钟来解释为什么会这样。
Starting with the most basic first principles. Your brain is constantly changing and constantly building new connections and different lobes and across different lobes and across different regions. A lot of people think of this as like electoral wiring or like your neurological wiring is like a bunch of roads or train lines or like a map, something like that. And it's much more like a forest, right? it's much more like a forest where seeds are planted, thousands of seeds, thousands of thoughts a day, thousands of potential habits are planted,
从最基本的首要原则开始。你的大脑在不断变化，不断建立新的连接，在不同的叶片中，跨越不同的叶片，跨越不同的区域。很多人认为这就像电子布线，或者你的神经布线就像一堆道路或火车线路，或者像一张地图，类似的东西。它更像是一片森林，对吧？它更像是一片森林，种子被种植，每天数千颗种子，数千个想法，数千个潜在的习惯被种植，
and only a couple hundred of saplings emerge. And then from those saplings, only a dozen or even less than that of those saplings turn into these big, strong pillars of your identity, these big, strong trees that make up your personality and make up your behavior. And the thing is, when you experience stress, when you see the world as dangerous, when you're overwhelmed, that forest that your brain wants to build and is constantly building day in and day out, a lot of those new structures can only get so big and tall. Your ability to develop new coping mechanisms, develop new behaviors, to change past behaviors, that growth is stunted. Your brain's ability to form new patterns is stunted because the external environment is hostile and it's scary.
只有几百棵树苗出现。然后从这些树苗中，只有十几棵甚至更少，变成了你身份的这些巨大、坚固的支柱，这些构成你个性和行为的巨大、坚固的树木。问题是，当你经历压力时，当你看到世界是危险的时，当你不知所措时，你的大脑想要建立并每天都在不断建立的那片森林，很多那些新的结构只能长到那么大和高。你发展新的应对机制、发展新行为、改变过去行为的能力，那种增长受到了阻碍。你大脑形成新模式的能力受到了阻碍，因为外部环境是敌对的，而且很可怕。
And so it becomes biologically harder to focus and form new patterns. This is simply because being in a state of stress or a state of real psychological negativity hijacks all of your resources whilst also suppressing dendric branching and neurogenesis, especially in this region called the hippocampus. That is the part that's basically called the learning center of the brain. Constant negativity and stress, it's not always our choice, but when you're, you can shift your brain to being playful in those environments and during these years of your life when things are just really intense, it's so helpful because you show your brain it's safe enough
因此，专注于并形成新模式在生物学上变得更加困难。这仅仅是因为处于压力状态或真正的心理消极状态会劫持你所有的资源，同时抑制树突分支和神经发生，特别是在这个被称为海马体的区域。那是基本上被称为大脑学习中心的部分。持续的消极和压力，这并不总是我们的选择，但当你，你可以在那些环境中，在你生命中的这些年里，当事情真的很紧张时，将你的大脑转变为俏皮，这非常有帮助，因为你向你的大脑展示它是足够安全的
to prioritize more than just its stress response. And it's safe enough to prioritize things that aren't just negative. There's this incredible research paper that was published last year titled Playful Brains, which is such a cute name. And it essentially says whimsy and play. keep your brain young because these activities require continuous adaptation and exploration. Whimsy, like how I like to see it in this kind of framework is like the rays of sunshine that like pour down on your neural forest and make it flourish. It is it is literally fertilizing the soil in which your brain can grow new connections. It's also a somatic strategy, right?
去优先考虑不仅仅是它的压力反应。而且它足够安全，可以优先考虑不仅仅是消极的事情。去年发表了一篇令人难以置信的研究论文，标题为《俏皮的大脑》，这是一个非常可爱的名字。它基本上说奇思妙想和游戏。让你的大脑保持年轻，因为这些活动需要持续的适应和探索。奇思妙想，就像我喜欢在这种框架中看待它的方式，就像倾泻在你神经森林上的阳光，让它繁荣。它字面上是在施肥你的大脑可以生长新连接的土壤。它也是一种躯体策略，对吧？
We're boosting oxytocin where it decreases cortisol. It's allowing your body and mind to shift from alert to safe and imaginative. And imagination, imagination is another big concept that makes whimsy so special and psychologically powerful. I feel like so many of these words that we're using today are like so synonymous with childhood, right? Imagination, play, joy, like, and that's not an accident. when is your brain forming the most connections during childhood? When were you likely the most optimistic you've ever been in your life during childhood? When did you have the biggest dreams during childhood?
我们正在促进催产素，它减少皮质醇。它让你的身体和思想从警觉转变为安全和富有想象力。而想象力，想象力是另一个让奇思妙想如此特别和心理强大的大概念。我觉得我们今天使用的这么多词汇都与童年如此同义，对吧？想象力、游戏、快乐，就像，这不是偶然的。你的大脑在什么时候形成最多的连接？在童年时期。你在生命中最乐观的时候可能是在什么时候？在童年时期。你什么时候有最大的梦想？在童年时期。
A lot of this is because we had permission to have fun. And having fun is a big part of how we learn to emotionally regulate and how we learn to just learn and test our surroundings. as much as that gets stripped from us in adulthood. Remember a few years ago, I don't know if, I'm sure we all remember this, actually. Inner child healing was like huge and like the internet was obsessed with it and people would have a childhood picture of themselves up on the mirror and they would buy themselves like the toys, like the littlest pet shops are like the beanie babies from childhood and they would
这很大程度上是因为我们被允许玩得开心。玩得开心是我们学习如何调节情绪以及我们如何学习和测试周围环境的重要组成部分。尽管这在成年后被剥夺了。记得几年前，我不知道，我相信我们都记得这个，实际上。内在小孩疗愈非常巨大，互联网对此非常着迷，人们会在镜子上放一张自己童年的照片，他们会给自己买像童年时期的玩具，像最小的宠物店或像豆豆娃，他们会
rewatch movies from when they were a kid and there was such a resurgence of like Hannah Montana and like people wanting those remakes. I think that's still kind of ongoing now because it is so fantastic, but this is exactly what, this is the practice that we're getting at, right? This is the fundamental stuff that we're getting back. We're getting at. Childhood was the last time many of us felt like ourselves and felt good about the world. Getting back to that and also mending the scars that were left on that version of us that still show up today, that is what prompts a lot of healing. And whimsy is a direct path to do. doing that. There's another thing I said before that I just want to quickly circle back on before I
重看他们小时候的电影，有像汉娜·蒙塔娜的复兴，人们想要那些翻拍。我认为这在现在仍然在进行中，因为它太棒了，但这正是，这是我们正在进行的练习，对吧？这是我们正在找回的基本东西。我们正在找回。童年是许多人最后一次感觉像自己并对世界感觉良好的时候。回到那个状态，同时也修复留在我们那个版本上的伤疤，这些伤疤今天仍然出现，这就是促使许多疗愈的原因。而奇思妙想是做到这一点的直接途径。我之前说的还有一件事，我想在之前快速回过头来
move on. Play as a form of emotional regulation. Literally, this may sound so weird, but whimsy is a form of emotional regulation. When you do arts and crafts, when you collect your little trinkets, you are essentially signaling to your brain, well, if I'm having fun, like it can't be that serious, right? Like, genuinely, they've done studies on this in Germany, in Malaysia, in the US, and play is essentially a signal to your nervous system that we are safe. And so it allows you to go from survival to engagement. So it's so important, like, don't let people make fun of you for this stuff. It is psychologically powerful for your nervous system and for your brain and every other system going on in your body. A couple of years ago,
继续。游戏作为一种情绪调节形式。字面上，这听起来可能很奇怪，但奇思妙想是一种情绪调节形式。当你做艺术和手工艺时，当你收集你的小饰品时，你基本上是在向你的大脑发出信号，好吧，如果我玩得很开心，就像它不可能那么严重，对吧？就像，真的，他们在德国、马来西亚、美国对此进行了研究，游戏基本上是向你的神经系统发出的信号，表明我们是安全的。所以它允许你从生存转向参与。所以这非常重要，就像，不要让人们因为这些东西而取笑你。这对你的神经系统和你的大脑以及你身体里进行的所有其他系统在心理上是强大的。几年前，
I got really into these adult coloring books. I feel like I talked about it on the show a bunch, but 30 minutes of that and I did more for me and my stress and my nervous system than I think most actual nervous system exercises that were given to me by a therapist. Now, that's not for everyone, but it worked for me. I really did reach like a flow state with this stuff and I experienced this like level of peace that I never had before all because I had these like pink and yellow and green markers. and I was able to switch my brain from hypervigilance to creative engagement. And that was what really made me feel better.
我真的很喜欢这些成人填色书。我觉得我在节目中谈论过很多次，但30分钟的填色对我以及我的压力和神经系统所做的贡献，我认为比治疗师给我的大多数实际神经系统练习都要多。现在，那并不适合每个人，但它对我有效。我确实通过这些东西达到了某种心流状态，我体验到了这种我以前从未有过的平静水平，所有这些都是因为我有这些粉色、黄色和绿色的记号笔。我能够将我的大脑从过度警觉切换到创造性参与。而那才是我真正感觉更好的原因。
A lot of people experience something similar, I think, with knitting, painting, because that, again, that creative activation, sorry to, like, beat a horse dead, but, like, that creative activation unconsciously says to your brain, hey, you're okay. Like, why else we would be making art if we weren't okay? On top of this, some research has even suggested that adult playfulness will make you more intelligent. People who are more playful in adulthood are smarter. A 2021 study published in the US actually looked at over 300 students, and it measured both their emotional intelligence and how playful they were.
很多人体验到类似的事情，我想，通过编织、绘画，因为那，再次，那种创造性激活，抱歉，像，鞭打死马，但，像，那种创造性激活无意识地对你的大脑说，嘿，你没问题。就像，如果我们没问题，我们为什么要制作艺术？最重要的是，一些研究甚至表明，成人俏皮感会让你更聪明。成年后更俏皮的人更聪明。2021年在美国发表的一项研究实际上观察了300多名学生，它测量了他们的情商和他们有多俏皮。
and what the study revealed, unsurprisingly, in their words, was that there was a strong, positive connection between intelligence and the more playful you were, or how fun-seeking you were. So this is what we're seeing so far, right? This is the point we keep kind of coming back to. Wimsy isn't just silly, it is psychologically protective during hard times. It helps your brain stay in an action. active state of rewiring, it helps you to regulate your emotions better than I think most
研究揭示的，不出所料，用他们的话说，是智力与你越俏皮，或你越追求乐趣之间存在强烈的正相关关系。所以这就是我们目前所看到的，对吧？这就是我们不断回到的点。奇思妙想不仅仅是愚蠢，它在困难时期在心理上具有保护作用。它帮助你的大脑保持在行动中。活跃的重塑状态，它帮助你比我认为大多数人更好地调节你的情绪
strategies we have as adults and it may make you more intelligent. It's just like so many wins to this that like we just cannot discount. And there's one final reason it's so powerful that I want to talk about as well before we get into how to make whimsy a habit. We're going to talk about that last significant reason after this short break. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical
我们作为成年人拥有的策略，它可能会让你更聪明。这就像有太多的胜利，我们简直不能忽视。还有最后一个原因它如此强大，我想在进入如何使奇思妙想成为一种习惯之前谈谈。我们将在短暂休息后讨论最后一个重要原因。所以请留下来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了在这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健康和建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康和健身专家以及更多人交谈，以看穿不切实际的
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
和过于复杂的伪科学，这些伪科学主导了健康产业。我们真的相信种子油本质上是炎症性的。我们错了。我们在世界上感到害怕的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在I-Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《2%》。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA上双击小金的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence.
包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克。需要明确的是，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我整天都愿意谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在桌面上还有艾滋病。谢谢你完成那句话。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite
是的。我认为没有比这更重要的黑人年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast上收听《Look Back at it》。或任何你收听播客的地方。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的
therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. and we don't know when we've done enough.
治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，并与许多令人难以置信的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于我们没有意识到我们已经拥有了那个东西。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够了。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free. iHeartRadio app search learn the hard way and listen now.
那是两种不同程度的信任。我希望你真的做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们将在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中进行关于疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目的的真实对话。打开你免费的。iHeartRadio应用程序搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars. were being used for.
2023年，前单身汉明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，在某人的，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
被用于什么。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭开一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯比安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over. until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们，先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。这还没结束。直到亚利桑那州伸张正义。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
第一条规则，永远不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条规则，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过。
I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends.
我感觉就像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们采取了行动。我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。请收听《The Girlfriends》。
Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. The final reason I think that Wimsy has some deep emotional power over us is because of how our brain responds to beauty. And so much of Wimsy is at the end of the day about creating beauty in like the most mundane stuff, making art, making things pretty for no reason, buying flowers just because you want to, like,
相信我，宝贝。在IHart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你收听播客的地方。我认为奇思妙想对我们有深厚情感力量的最后一个原因是由于我们的大脑对美的反应。归根结底，奇思妙想的很大一部分是在最平凡的事情中创造美，制作艺术，无缘无故地让事情变得漂亮，仅仅因为你想买花，就像，
bringing in color and all those kinds of stuff. It's just trying to make the world more beautiful and lovely. I read this phenomenal substack the other day by this writer who goes by plum pits. And it just stopped me in my tracks because she was talking about this. And she was talking about this distinct field of research called neuroaesthetics, which essentially explains what we're talking about, right? How the brain reacts to beauty and how powerful that is. In the late 20th century, there was this one man in particular, this Turkish neurobiologist
引入色彩和所有这些东西。它只是试图让世界变得更美丽、更可爱。前几天我读了这位笔名为Plum Pits的作家写的一篇非凡的Substack。它让我停下了脚步，因为她在谈论这个。她在谈论一个被称为神经美学的独特研究领域，它基本上解释了我们正在谈论的内容，对吧？大脑如何对美做出反应，以及这有多强大。在20世纪末，有一个人特别，这位土耳其神经生物学家
who is still alive today and he became really fascinated with this. He was like, why do our brains or how do our brains respond to beauty in such a different way to how they respond to the rest of the world? And he started doing these very simple experiments to try and kind of figure out what was happening behind the scenes. these experiments was just so basic and so profound. He would essentially just show people different kinds of art and music, and he would just look using fMRIs and EEGs.
他今天还活着，他对这一点非常着迷。他想，为什么我们的大脑或我们的大脑如何以与它们对世界其他部分的反应如此不同的方式对美做出反应？他开始做这些非常简单的实验，试图弄清楚幕后发生了什么。这些实验非常基础且深刻。他基本上只是向人们展示不同种类的艺术和音乐，他只是使用fMRI和EEG进行观察。
He would just see how their brains responded, what parts of their brains were lighting up, what parts of their brains weren't. He found that our response to beauty isn't sectioned. It's not singular. It activates almost every single region of the brain all at once. So, yes, your sense. cortex is obviously going to be involved.
他只是观察他们的大脑如何反应，他们大脑的哪些部分亮起，哪些部分没有。他发现我们对美的反应不是分段的。它不是单一的。它几乎同时激活大脑的每一个区域。所以，是的，你的感官。皮层显然会参与其中。
The parts of your brain that are responsible for seeing and hearing and feeling are going to be involved. But then it was also the medial oboeuvr frontal cortex, which is involved in evaluating meaning. And also chasing what feels good, that that part of our brain was like on fire. And also the emotional parts of our brain, the emotional cause of our brain, which also influence our nervous system response, showed a big reaction when we saw beauty, when we saw art. the emotional activation that beauty brings, that is why we feel emotional and we hear like wonderful music. That is why we like sometimes cry when we see art or like feel intense happiness but also sadness when we see like a thousand year old church or we see the sun hitting the tulips that we got for $599 on the way home from work.
负责视觉、听觉和感觉的大脑部分将参与其中。但随后还有内侧眶额皮层，它参与评估意义。还有追逐感觉良好的东西，我们大脑的那部分就像着火了一样。还有我们大脑的情感部分，我们大脑的情感核心，它们也影响我们的神经系统反应，当我们看到美，当我们看到艺术时，表现出巨大的反应。美带来的情感激活，这就是为什么我们感到情感，我们听到美妙的音乐。这就是为什么我们有时在看到艺术时会哭，或者当我们看到千年教堂或看到阳光照射到我们下班回家路上以5.99美元买的郁金香时，会感到强烈的快乐但也有悲伤。
beauty elicits awe. It elicits wonder, it elicits gratitude. It will just make you cry from happiness and cry from just wonder. And that obviously has a neurobiological impact. There was one University of Michigan study that found that our appreciation for beauty in this way and our everyday, I don't know, our everyday preference for what looks, lovely and pretty. When we experience more of that, that decreases inflammation. It reduces risk of depression, risk of diabetes, risk of cardiovascular disease. When people say, you know,
美能激发敬畏感。它能激发惊奇，激发感激。它会让你因幸福而落泪，因惊奇而流泪。这显然具有神经生物学上的影响。密歇根大学的一项研究发现，我们以这种方式对美的欣赏，以及我们日常生活中对看起来可爱、漂亮事物的偏好，当我们体验到更多这些事物时，炎症就会减少。它能降低患抑郁症、糖尿病和心血管疾病的风险。当人们说，你知道，
art isn't important or nature isn't important or whatever other crap people say, like, I don't want to hear it because this is what the science says. This is what you need to remind them of. Practices and activities that bring the beauty of life to the surface and make things look pretty and aesthetic and lovely and which feel good to look at, that's life-changing. That's not, that's not like a benign thing. That is truly powerful. And dare I say, I honestly think that whimsy and beauty are as spiritual in some ways as prayer or traditions or celebrations or repenting or sacrifice. your body, for whatever mysterious and wonderful reason, wants you to experience more of this. And it wants you to, it's just such positive signs that this is an experience we should be chasing.
艺术不重要，或者自然不重要，或者人们说的其他废话，我不想听，因为科学就是这么说的。这就是你需要提醒他们的。那些将生活之美带到表面，让事物看起来漂亮、美观、可爱，并且让人看着感觉良好的实践和活动，是能够改变生活的。这绝非无关紧要的小事。这是真正强大的力量。我甚至敢说，我真心认为奇思妙想和美在某种程度上与祈祷、传统、庆祝、忏悔或牺牲一样具有灵性。你的身体，出于某种神秘而美妙的原因，希望你体验更多这样的事物。这些都是积极的信号，表明这是一种我们应该追求的体验。
And also, just to add to that, I think this is something about Wimsy we really need to concentrate on more. So often, if we want it to be, like, a lot of these examples are free or very affordable. And these days, so much of what is meant to help us out mentally is very expensive. Therapy is very expensive. I genuinely, I think I pay my therapist 200 pounds a session. That is an insane amount. Self-care practices are very expensive, especially in the way that they're marketed to us these days.
另外，我想补充一点，我认为关于“奇思妙想”这一点，我们确实需要更加关注。很多时候，如果我们愿意的话，这些例子中有很多是免费的，或者非常实惠。而如今，很多旨在帮助我们心理健康的东西都非常昂贵。治疗非常昂贵。我真的，我想我每次治疗要付给我的治疗师200英镑。这是一个疯狂的数字。自我护理实践非常昂贵，尤其是以如今向我们推销的方式。
And whimsy, on the other hand, is a very affordable practice. And yes, it's currently being commercialized and it's being turned into products. and into an aesthetic that you can buy. But being a little bit silly, leaving like a secret note in a library book, painting rocks and leaving them for others to find, random acts of kindness, that costs you nothing, if not very, very little.
另一方面，奇思妙想是一种非常实惠的实践。是的，它目前正在被商业化，被转化为产品，变成一种你可以购买的审美。但是，做一点点傻事，比如在图书馆的书里留下一张秘密纸条，画一些石头留给别人发现，做一些随机的善举，这些几乎不需要花钱，或者花费极少。
So if you want to fully capture the power of all of this whimsical, magical, wonderful thinking, let's talk about A, some fun examples of activities that you can, can do and B, how to turn whimsy from something that you do occasionally into an actual habit. I had my own list of like activities, whimsical activities, ready to go. And then I thought, actually, I'm going to ask you guys, hence why I have my phone. Let me make sure that's on silence since I'm in the studio. I always forget to do that. But when you guys sent me your responses, I just, I scrapped my list.
所以，如果你想充分捕捉所有这些奇思妙想、神奇、美妙思维的力量，让我们来谈谈：A，一些你可以做的有趣活动的例子；B，如何将奇思妙想从偶尔为之变成一种真正的习惯。我准备好了自己的“奇思妙想活动”清单。然后我想，其实，我要问问你们，这就是为什么我拿着手机。让我确保它处于静音状态，因为我在录音室里。我总是忘记这样做。但当你们发给我回复时，我直接放弃了我的清单。
and I decided just to go with what you guys were saying because you guys gave me such creative, amazing ideas that you guys do. And I just not surprised because we have some very creative people who listen. But I want to read out some of these to you for inspiration. If you're thinking about whimsy and like kind of coming up blank. Okay. If you're ready, here we go. This first one comes from Jeannie. And this was one of my favorites.
我决定直接采用你们所说的，因为你们给出的那些你们自己做的创意十足、令人惊叹的点子。我一点也不惊讶，因为我们的听众中有很多非常有创意的人。但我还是想读出其中一些给你们作为灵感。如果你在思考“奇思妙想”时感到毫无头绪。好吧，如果你准备好了，我们开始吧。第一个来自珍妮。这是我最喜欢的例子之一。
She says, I say hi and buy to my car. whenever I drive him. Firstly, love that she said him, like she's personalized, like personified him. That is so cute. There were surprisingly so many that were car related. People who would like thank their car, people who would like decorate their cars, very car focused whimsical activities on this list. This next one, I say thank you to my candles before I blow them out. I say a spell and I wish myself a good day when I apply perfume in the morning. When I have to do my, uh, skin care, I apply my moisturiser or my sunscreen in a heart on my face. That is so cute. I'm going to steal that one. I unbagged my groceries like I'm filming a hall for my boyfriend, even though we just bought them all
她说，我每次开车时都会跟我的车说“嗨”和“拜拜”。首先，我很喜欢她用了“他”这个词，就像她把车人格化了一样。这太可爱了。令人惊讶的是，清单上有这么多与车相关的例子。有人会感谢他们的车，有人会装饰他们的车，这个清单上有很多以车为中心的奇思妙想活动。下一个，我在吹灭蜡烛前会说谢谢。我在早上喷香水时会念一句咒语，祝自己度过美好的一天。当我不得不做护肤时，我会把润肤霜或防晒霜在脸上涂成一个心形。这太可爱了。我要偷学这一招。我拆开杂货袋时，就像在为我的男朋友拍开箱视频一样，尽管我们是一起买的。
together. Cute. I have a monthly newsletter with my best friend called the whimsy sisters. That one's from Maya. Maya, that is a great idea. Honestly, if any of my friends are listening to this, Emma, Kate, Sarah, I'm thinking about you guys. I feel like this is a great idea, a whimsy newsletter or a monthly newsletter, sorry, Maya, we're going to steal your whimsy sister's name for like your long-distance friends would be just such a great way of staying in touch. This next one as well, I just thought was so genius. Is genius the right word? I think genius is the right word. I put fun sprinkles in my oatmeal and yogurt bowls to add a bit of
可爱。我和我最好的朋友有一个月刊通讯，叫“奇思妙想姐妹”。那个是玛雅发的。玛雅，这真是个好主意。老实说，如果我的任何朋友在听这个节目，艾玛、凯特、莎拉，我在想你们。我觉得这是一个很棒的主意，一个“奇思妙想通讯”或者月刊通讯，抱歉，玛雅，我们要借用你的“奇思妙想姐妹”这个名字，对于异地恋的朋友来说，这真是保持联系的好方法。下一个我也觉得太天才了。天才这个词用对了吗？我想天才这个词很合适。我在燕麦片和酸奶碗里放上有趣的糖针，为我的早晨增添一点
whimsy to my morning. How have I never thought about that? Like, that's such a great idea. I leave notes on napkins at restaurants and cafes when the service was really good. I talk to my plants and I tell them that I love them when I water them. That is so special. I drink any drink I want in wine glass, milk, diet, Coke, water, whatever, because I can. I have a weekly ferry walk I go on where I pretend I'm a fairy observing the world for the first time. I twirl in circles, I spread some magic, and I pretend that I'm leaving a glitter trail wherever I go. This actually brings me to the story of why I have this one, because I did something similar the other day with my friend Jack. And if you follow me on Instagram, maybe you saw this real, but both of us have been definitely
奇思妙想。我怎么从来没想过这个？这真是个好主意。当服务特别好时，我会在餐馆和咖啡馆的餐巾纸上留下纸条。我跟我的植物说话，浇水时告诉它们我爱它们。这太特别了。我用红酒杯喝任何我想喝的饮料，牛奶、健怡可乐、水，什么都行，因为我可以。我每周有一次“仙女漫步”，我假装自己是一个第一次观察世界的仙女。我原地旋转，散播一些魔法，假装我所到之处都留下了闪闪发光的痕迹。这让我想起了为什么我有这个习惯的故事，因为前几天我和我的朋友杰克做了类似的事情。如果你在Instagram上关注我，也许你看到了那个短视频，但我们俩都绝对
feeling like the sad, the seasonal effective disorder of the London winter, of the UK winter, especially coming from Australia. Like, I just don't think my body. is built for this. But we went on this walk in Hampstead Heath and we were, as we were walking down from like the train station, there's this magic shop and we, I don't know why we walked in. It's like a puppet, a puppet and a magic shop. And we walked in and they were selling these ones, that one over there, for like $5.99 or something not that expensive. And we just kind of looked at each other and we were like, we should just, we should just buy one of these and we should go for a little walk and we should spread some magic and we should, I don't know, we just were like running around the park, honestly
感受到了伦敦冬天的忧郁，那种季节性情绪失调，尤其是从澳大利亚过来的人。我觉得我的身体根本不适应这个。但我们在汉普斯特德荒野散步时，我们正从火车站走下来，那里有一家魔法商店，我们，我不知道为什么我们走了进去。那是一家木偶和魔法商店。我们走进去，他们正在卖这些魔杖，就是那边那个，只要5.99美元左右，并不贵。我们互相看了看，心想，我们应该买一个，然后去散散步，散播一些魔法，我们，我不知道，我们就像在公园里跑来跑去，老实说，
slipping in a lot of the mud and just like spreading magic and any time like it was quite funny. Like obviously we were like making little noises and like waving this big magic stick around and there's like a bunch of dogs there and all the dogs were kind of going like a little bit crazy for it. I think they probably didn't realize they just thought we were weird, which makes sense, right? Or they thought we were like trying to play like fetch with And it was just the most magical day I've had in a while. I genuinely felt like I was glowing for the rest of the afternoon, like vibrationalally, emotionally.
在泥地里滑倒，只是在散播魔法，任何时候，这都相当有趣。显然我们发出了一些小声音，挥舞着这根大魔法棒，那里有一群狗，所有的狗都因为这个有点疯狂。我想它们可能没意识到，只是觉得我们很奇怪，这很合理，对吧？或者它们以为我们在试图跟它们玩捡球游戏。那是我最近度过的最神奇的一天。我真心觉得那天下午剩下的时间里我都在发光，从振动频率上，从情感上。
It was like I had done some like energetic cleanse or like some mental detox. I just felt phenomenal. And part of that is what's inspired this episode, right? Thinking about why I felt that great and why there must be some kind of science to the transformation it kind of gave me, even just for a day. And that's the other thing with whimsy, right? You can either ritualize it or you can just use it as like a spontaneous mood pick me up.
就像我做了一次能量净化或心理排毒。我感觉棒极了。这部分启发了这一集，对吧？思考为什么我感觉那么好，以及为什么这种转变背后一定有某种科学依据，即使只是一天。这就是奇思妙想的另一面，对吧？你可以把它仪式化，或者你可以把它当作一种自发的提神剂。
There is definitely evidence though. As much as like those one-off things are amazing, the more you ritualize your whimsy, the better. As long as it's not like too burdensome. I know this may sound very like contra to what we've been discussing this whole time. you know, whimsy is meant to be spontaneous and sporadic and playful. That's like the whole nature of this. But what I mean by ritualizing whimsy is that making it a daily or a weekly priority
当然是有证据的。尽管那些一次性的事情很棒，但你越是将奇思妙想仪式化，效果就越好。只要它不会太沉重。我知道这听起来可能与我们一直在讨论的内容相悖。你知道，奇思妙想应该是自发的、零星的和有趣的。这就是它的本质。但我所说的仪式化奇思妙想，是指将其作为每天或每周的优先事项，
rather than something you just do when like you just feel really crap is going to bring about a lot more of those mental and emotional results. Tying your whimsy especially to something you do every day. Like that perfume example or the moisturizer example or the glass example, that increases how easily you're going to be able to see whimsy and happiness and joy everywhere else. And I think it will also increase like the long term positive dose that your brain and your body will get from, you know, the psychological power of whimsy. making it a daily practice the way that you make exercise a daily practice or you make hygiene or sleep a daily practice is something we could definitely all benefit from especially in this day and age I would also say remind yourself that most whimsy should cost you nothing that's what I really
而不是当你感觉真的很糟糕时才做的事情，这样会带来更多心理和情感上的成果。将你的奇思妙想特别与你每天做的事情联系起来。比如那个香水的例子，或者润肤霜的例子，或者杯子的例子，这会增加你发现奇思妙想、幸福和快乐的容易程度。我认为它也会增加你的大脑和身体从奇思妙想的心理力量中获得的长期积极剂量。像对待锻炼、卫生或睡眠一样，将其作为一种日常实践，是我们所有人绝对都能从中受益的事情，尤其是在这个时代。我还要说，提醒自己，大多数奇思妙想应该是不花钱的，这就是我真的很
liked about a lot of those examples people sent in I kind of keep returning to this but you don't need the $200 art kit and you don't need to host like an expensive themed dress-up night or whatever else to feel the positive effects. There is no hierarchy. There is no kind of, the more money you spend on whimsy, the better. In fact, a lot of research says that the most organic and rudimentary forms of play, the better the joy is, the deeper the joy is, because it actually allows for more gratitude towards the ordinary,
喜欢人们发来的那些例子的地方。我一直在回到这一点，但你不需要200美元的艺术套装，也不需要举办昂贵的主题装扮之夜或其他什么来感受积极的影响。没有等级之分。并不是说你在奇思妙想上花的钱越多越好。事实上，很多研究表明，最有机和最原始的游戏形式，快乐的效果越好，快乐就越深，因为它实际上允许对平凡的事物产生更多的感激之情，
rather than needing to do something extraordinary to feel good. Basically, when you try to force whimsy, when you try to buy whimsy, you actually lose a fundamental part of it, which is that it is about the mundane. It is about recognizing what is simply around you and making that special. The big events, the big shows, the parties, like, that's actually, that's great and that's a lot of fun. But it's not what whimsy is about. and it does not make whimsy sustainable. Also, whilst I'm at it, another thing you can do to definitely, like, elevate your whimsy is, yeah, make it affordable and involve other people.
而不是需要做一些非凡的事情来感觉良好。基本上，当你试图强迫奇思妙想，当你试图购买奇思妙想时，你实际上失去了它最基本的部分，那就是它关乎平凡。它关乎识别你周围简单的事物并使其变得特别。大型活动、大型演出、派对，那确实很棒，也很有趣。但那不是奇思妙想的意义所在。而且这并不能使奇思妙想具有可持续性。另外，顺便说一句，你可以做的另一件绝对能提升你奇思妙想的事情是，是的，让它变得实惠并让其他人参与进来。
This taps into something we know in developmental psychology as parallel play. When true people, often in this case children, engage in playful activities side by side, it is really, really powerful and really, really healing. going further and then involving somebody, not just doing it next to each other, but involving somebody in your stories and in your imagination. You know, both of you trying not to step on the cracks, both of you waving your ones around, both of you looking for the four-leaf clover, like whatever it is, whether it's your boyfriend, it's your friend, it's your siblings. That can literally be a form of co-regulation. You know, we mentioned self-regulation a lot at the beginning and how whimsy is an emotional regulation. but when you are with another person and you're feeling calm, you're feeling magical,
这触及了我们在发展心理学中称为“平行游戏”的概念。当两个人，通常在这种情况下是儿童，并排进行游戏活动时，它是非常、非常强大且非常、非常治愈的。更进一步，让某人参与进来，不仅仅是并排做，而是让某人参与到你的故事和想象中。你知道，你们俩都尽量不去踩裂缝，你们俩都挥舞着魔杖，你们俩都在寻找四叶草，无论是什么，无论是你的男朋友，你的朋友，还是你的兄弟姐妹。这实际上可以是一种共同调节的形式。你知道，我们在开头提到了很多自我调节，以及奇思妙想是如何进行情绪调节的。但当你和另一个人在一起，你感到平静，你感到神奇，
you're feeling creative and playful, that internal mindset, that internal feeling, that's contagious. If you've ever heard of the term mirror neurons, which I'm sure you have at this point, especially if you're a psychology student, mirror neurons, this is exactly what is at play here. Mirror neurons are essentially the mind's social mirror. And specifically to kind of explain it more, it's why when you see someone else doing something or you see somebody else performing a behavior, or you see somebody else singing or whatever it is, a part of you automatically responds to them and wants to copy what that person is doing and wants to copy their behavior and get involved.
你感到有创造力和有趣，那种内在的心态，那种内在的感觉，是会传染的。如果你听说过“镜像神经元”这个词，我相信你肯定听说过，尤其是如果你是心理学专业的学生，镜像神经元，这正是这里发挥作用的东西。镜像神经元本质上是大脑的社交镜子。具体来说，为了更好地解释它，这就是为什么当你看到别人做某事，或者看到别人表现出某种行为，或者看到别人唱歌或其他什么时，你的一部分会自动回应他们，想要模仿那个人正在做的事情，想要模仿他们的行为并参与其中。
I don't know, guys, I just whimsy because of that and how it activates mirror neurons and how it's contagious. I think that's why it's so life-changing and why it could really change the world and make us all hopefully a happier species if we just invited more people in. Because it's so organic and it's so like in our DNA to find purpose just in simple beauty and in the ordinary. And I feel like a lot of technology and a lot of rapid advancements and a lot of what's going on in the world right now has made that feel very inaccessible. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%.
我不知道，伙计们，我只是因为这个，以及它如何激活镜像神经元，以及它是如何传染的，才喜欢奇思妙想。我认为这就是为什么它如此改变生活，以及为什么如果我们邀请更多人参与，它真的可以改变世界，让我们所有人成为一个更快乐的物种。因为它如此有机，而且在我们的DNA中，在简单的美和平凡中找到目标。我觉得很多技术、很多快速的进步以及世界上正在发生的事情，让这种感觉变得非常遥不可及。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我剖析了心理韧性、健身和在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家等交谈，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的。我们错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。那是T-W-O-Percent，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了两次小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会选定一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图弄清楚我们是如何幸存下来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crime. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence.
包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，大谈80年代的快克。明确一点，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为犯罪。快克。我愿意谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条主线。我们现在手头还有艾滋病。谢谢你完成那句话。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me,
我不认为对黑人来说有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人来说最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是
your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多令人难以置信的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够多了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines,
史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得做一个好人很重要，所以你才在地球上？你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，
as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序，搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争，以证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini.
你给这个人做了两次这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了测试一次。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. served in Arizona.
我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of The Girlfriends,
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。第一条，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。第二条，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中，
Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都约会过同一个多产的骗子。我觉得我被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们采取了行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Before we leave this topic behind, before we close out our episode on the psychology of whimsy,
他会得到他应得的。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。在我们离开这个话题之前，在我们结束关于奇思妙想心理学的这一集之前，
one quick caveat. Whimsy is very special. It is very beautiful. It is not the solution to all of our problems. I know somebody is going to come to me, somebody's going to come at me, like in the comments, in my DMs and be like, you still need therapy and we still need stronger social supports
一个简短的警告。奇思妙想非常特别。它非常美妙。但它不是我们所有问题的解决方案。我知道有人会来找我，有人会在评论区、在我的私信里攻击我，说你仍然需要治疗，我们仍然需要更强大的社会支持，
and you still need good mental health habits. like whimsy is not that important. Let's make that very clear. Yes, you cannot just play mermaids in the pool and think that that is your dose of good psychological vibes for the month. I feel like a lot of you already know this without me, but I just, it goes without saying, or I feel like I have to say it,
你仍然需要良好的心理健康习惯。奇思妙想没那么重要。让我们把这一点说清楚。是的，你不能只是在游泳池里玩美人鱼，就认为那是你这个月所需的良好心理氛围。我觉得你们很多人不用我说就已经知道了，但我只是，这不言而喻，或者我觉得我必须说出来，
whimsy cannot be everything, especially right now. You know, I see a lot of people being like, joy is resistance, joy is protective, joy is power, and it is all of those things, but don't let it become an avoidance technique. I guess what I'm saying is don't let your whimsy turn into just another reason to spend money or pure hedonism where you only prioritize pleasure, you only prioritize you feeling good without thinking about
奇思妙想不能是一切，尤其是在现在。你知道，我看到很多人说，快乐就是抵抗，快乐就是保护，快乐就是力量，它确实是所有这些东西，但不要让它成为一种逃避技巧。我想说的是，不要让你的奇思妙想变成另一个花钱的理由，或者纯粹的享乐主义，即你只优先考虑快乐，你只优先考虑你感觉良好，而不考虑
your community or thinking about those around you. Just like keep it in the balance. And I'm, I don't want to end on like, kind of a more, I don't want to end on like a realistic, like, kind of down a tone, but I just think it's important. I just think it's, whimsy is so fantastic. It cannot be everything. It is like any other psychological tool, great in small doses. Let's wrap up the episode, shall we?
你的社区或考虑你周围的人。保持平衡就好。我不想以一种更现实、更低沉的基调结束，但我只是觉得这很重要。我只是觉得，奇思妙想太棒了。它不能是一切。它就像任何其他心理工具一样，小剂量使用效果很好。让我们结束这一集，好吗？
I feel like that's everything I have to talk about. I'm sure there's more that I've forgotten about. But you know what? Before we leave, I want to continue. you that list. If you are listening on Spotify, what is your whimsical practice that we did not include in this episode? What is something that you do to keep the sparkle alive, to keep that like childlike goodness alive? I really want to hear from you guys. I really want to make this, maybe I'll make like a big collaborative list or like wincey bucket list for all of us to,
我觉得这就是我要谈的一切。我相信还有更多我忘记了。但你知道吗？在我们离开之前，我想继续那个清单。如果你在Spotify上收听，我们在这一集中没有包括什么奇思妙想的实践？你做些什么来保持火花，保持那种孩子般的善良？我真的很想听听你们的意见。我真的很想把这个，也许我会做一个大的协作清单，或者一个奇思妙想愿望清单，让我们所有人，
I don't know, for all of us to like to start. ticking things off and to kind of share in. So thank you for listening to this episode. Thank you for tuning in. I hope you found it joyful. I hope you got some inspiration from it. I hope you liked my tiara, especially if you were watching on Netflix. Make sure that you were following us on Instagram at that psychology podcast. Following us on Substack. If you want to read the transcript and all the papers that we referenced in this episode, that is where you can find them. But until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Enjoy some whimsy today and we will talk very, very soon.
我不知道，让我们所有人开始勾选清单上的事情，并分享。所以感谢收听这一集。感谢收听。我希望你觉得它很愉快。我希望你从中得到了一些灵感。我希望你喜欢我的头饰，尤其是如果你在Netflix上观看的话。确保你在Instagram上关注我们@thatpsychologypodcast。关注我们的Substack。如果你想阅读本集引用的文字记录和所有论文，那就是你可以找到它们的地方。但直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。今天享受一些奇思妙想，我们很快就会再聊。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side. a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%? That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身和在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》？那是TWA%，在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。
84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. Before it was a wild year. It was a wild year.
84年对我来说很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会选定一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图弄清楚我们是如何幸存下来的。与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。在那之前，那是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
我不认为对黑人来说有比这更重要的一年了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人，基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，在任何其他地方进行这些对话都不安全，但你正在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要使用它，
listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Rancini.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcast或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控让双胞胎怀孕。但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，埃伦女士，对吧？我篡改了测试一次。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰西尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all day to do. the same prolific con artist.
我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都约会过同一个多产的骗子时。
They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
她们采取了行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts，
or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或任何你获取播客的地方。这是一个iHeart播客。保证是人类。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。